ADAM QUAYLE: Thanks
for coming, everyone.
I'm Adam Quayle, and
I'm really excited to be
hosting Ashanti Branch today.
Ashanti is a lot of things.
He's the founder and
executive director
of the Ever Forward Club,
which we'll learn about today.
He's also an education fellow
at the Stanford d.school.
And he's also assistant
principal at Montero Middle
School in the East Bay.
And so today Ashanti
is going to take us
through the Taking
Off the Mask exercise.
So I hope you're all
ready to get really
real with your
coworkers, because it's
going to get real in here.
And then we're going to learn
a little bit about how the Ever
Forward Club is helping young
men in the East Bay and beyond.
And you'll hear from
some of the students that
have benefit directly from it.
So with that I'd love to
welcome Ashanti Branch.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Good afternoon.
So Adam probably made you a
little nervous when he's like,
are you ready to get
real with your coworkers?
I think that when we
talk about getting real,
sometimes that's a very--
it means different things
to different people.
So we're not going
to start there.
I'm gonna start by getting
really real with you about me.
So I'm more nervous than usual
because my mom's in the room.
And she's never heard
me present before.
I don't know if she's
ever watched me present,
but I know she's never
been to one of my talks--
at least my new talk.
And I talk a lot about her.
So this morning I
was like, oh, man.
How do I change that talk?
How do I not say
all the stuff I say?
And I had to call her
yesterday for help.
I had to call her
As an adult man,
because I didn't have
enough drivers to get
all the young men
here, and so I had
to ask her for help yesterday.
And she said, OK.
And so I said, well, why would
I change the talk to try and not
talk about her when the reason
I'm standing here alive, free,
educated is because of her?
Of her sacrifice?
My father died three
months before I was born.
His father died three
months before he died.
So six months leading
up to my birth,
I lost both my
grandfather and my father,
and no one gave me a
choice in the matter.
I just showed up
here on the Earth,
out of Bates hospital, popped
out, and there was problems.
Like, if you handed me
a checklist in the womb,
and I had a choice, I
would have chosen things
that looked pretty different.
Like I would have chosen
to have two parents,
to maybe live in a house.
To maybe live in a community
where being smart was OK.
Or like being your best wasn't
like making other people feel
bad, but being your
best was absolutely--
people were pushing you to
be better than your best.
But I didn't get that, either.
So I grew up in
Oakland, California.
I knew there were
certain ways I had
to behave and act that would
give me either respect, or not.
And there was a very
short list of what
it meant to be a
man-- a boy growing
into be a man-- in
Oakland, where I grew up.
Like when you're a boy,
you have to be a man.
Like they're
telling you, man up.
Be tough.
Don't show no emotions.
Can you imagine my first
day of fourth grade,
showing up at a
new school, excited
to be in this new
school in the hills.
It was incredible.
There was no apartments
around there.
It was all houses.
It was beautiful.
I had a fight my first
day of fourth grade
because a guy was like,
we're playing tag.
Fourth graders play tag, right?
We're playing tag.
He tags me.
I said, OK.
I'm in.
You should be running.
But he tags me again.
I said, why do you
keep tagging me?
I'm already it.
He tags me again, and I
realized he's not tagging me.
He's hitting me.
Now, I also know certain rules.
At fourth grade, I
already know that if I
let this keep
happening-- this is
in the moment of a
couple of seconds.
I'm processing.
If I let this keep happening,
everybody at this new school
is going to think they
could be hitting me.
I don't wanna fight.
I don't even like to fight.
But in that moment, I knew
that something had to happen.
I can either take it and
then be a victim the rest
of these years in
elementary school,
or I could do
something about it.
If you're not the kind of person
who really likes fighting,
that's a hard decision.
I was raised by my mother.
She taught me to be really nice.
But nice doesn't work so
well on the playground
for a young, black boy
growing up in Oakland.
Being kind and being
gentle doesn't really
help you be looked at as
somebody who people were
like, man, he's incredible.
Actually, it makes
you look weak, soft.
They call you many
names that would
fit in the soft/weak category.
They're usually
not very positive.
And so I was so thankful
that, throughout elementary,
you're only in a class with
maybe 25 people, so being smart
is kind of OK.
You can kind of be smart
with those 25 people.
Not too many people bother you.
But when you get
to middle school,
it's a whole other
world, because you've
got 180 kids you got to
deal with, six classes.
You gotta be in PE.
You gotta be in
and out of classes.
You gotta shift your
behavior so many times a day.
And I learned that
smart wasn't cool.
So even though I maybe,
in my back of my mind,
though I was smart, that
was not what I was showing.
Now, for me, math was easy.
So I could do math.
We played a lot of math games
at my house, so math was easy.
So I was passing math
without a problem.
But English-- I didn't
really like English.
I didn't really like
science, history.
Didn't really like
anything else.
Didn't really like PE.
So I just did barely enough
so that my mom wouldn't trip--
so C-.
I can kind of talk
my way out of it.
Can't come home with no Ds.
Every once in a while
I'd fall into the D range
and couldn't climb out, and
that would be like a half
hour lecture about something.
I don't really
remember much of it.
But I want you know that middle
school, I was in trouble.
If you saw me in
middle school-- if you
walked to my middle
school campus and saw me,
you would never have
said, this guy's
going to speaking to
companies one day.
You wouldn't be
like, they're going
to study what this
guy's doing one day,
because my behavior
was definitely
not leading me to toward
being educated in any way.
And so my life began
to get really chaotic
in middle school.
Middle school was that
place where you now
are beginning to be tested.
Your body's growing.
Your mind is saying,
hey I want to do this,
but people around you are
saying, you can't do that.
And so you're beginning
trying to figure out
your world around you.
Getting bullied?
Having somebody might
take your lunch money?
That was happening.
I couldn't tell mom about it.
First of all, how do
I deal with it myself
that I let that happen--
that I was afraid enough
to let somebody take my
money, and I gave it to him.
That was really
tough to deal with.
So I kept it to myself.
And I think the only
way she figured it out
is because every time I'd
come home after school,
I was super hungry.
And there was already not a lot
of things in the refrigerator
anyway, so she would know
when something was missing
because I was eating lunch and
breakfast at the same time,
kind of.
And it wasn't until
that moment, where
I was like, this
can't happen anymore.
Another moment in my life,
being in seventh grade,
where you're like, OK.
I gotta stop this
from happening.
What if you're afraid?
What if the people who
are pushing on you,
making you do something
you don't want to do,
but you're afraid to
like stand against them?
What do you do?
Well, it becomes a very
scary day to have to be like,
I'm actually really
afraid, but I'm actually
going to have to face this fear
because if this doesn't stop
now, it's going to keep going.
And so it wasn't
until middle school,
around the eighth grade,
moving into ninth grade, where
a teacher really
pulled me aside.
She said, you're
really smart, but you
don't act like you're not.
I know that you're upset
that your father died
before you were born.
I know that you're
upset about that.
Maybe you're sad about that.
I'm like, I ain't sad.
When she said upset,
I was cool with it.
I'll be upset,
because you can be
upset as a young man
in Oakland, but don't
be talking about me being sad.
I think deep down
I was really sad.
When I would see kids get
dropped off by their fathers,
or get picked up
by their fathers,
or get chastised by their
fathers, I was like,
I want that.
And it wasn't till
she said to me,
life doesn't give
you what you want.
Life gives you what
you get, and you have
to make the most out of it.
And in that half hour
lecture she was giving me
at that moment, that's the
only sentence I remember,
but it absolutely
changed my life.
And so I get my act
together, go to high school.
I'm going to go to college.
I hear there's a program
called Upward Bound.
They help you get to college.
First generation college
student-- I'm like, excellent.
Turn in my application.
The lady calls me into
the office and said, hey.
I said, all right.
Where do I start?
She's like, well, I
have some bad news.
What do you mean bad news?
I want to go to college.
You help people get to college.
She's like, well, you're
not first generation college
student.
I was like, of course I am.
Nobody went to
college in my family.
She was like, your
mom went to college.
Your mom's a teacher.
I'm like, we don't
make no money.
Don't you go to
college to make money?
Why are we broke?
And I knew that day I
would never be a teacher.
I was clear that I would
never, ever be a teacher.
I'm like, OK, if I'm
going to college,
I ain't going to be no teacher,
because teachers don't make
money, and we got
teachers at my house,
as much as I love my mom.
So I went home that day,
pretty upset with her.
What do you mean,
we went to college
and we are just barely
able to make it?
It was an awakening for me.
So I knew then I
was good at math.
Science started
getting better for me.
I'm gonna start
paying attention.
I'm going to be an engineer.
Graduate high school, go to
college for civil engineering.
Start working, making money.
Great.
Working, making money--
I could pay rent
and PG&E the same month and
still have money for food?
That's a big deal.
But why am I not happy?
How in the world am I able to--
like, poor boy from Oakland
goes to college, becomes
an engineer, making money,
and I'm not happy?
They told me that was what
the secret to happiness was.
You make a lot of money.
You're gonna go do fun things,
never miss a bachelor party.
You go everywhere
when you have money.
But I'm not happy.
And what happened to me
in the next year or two
was not planned by any--
definitely not my plan.
So I'm gonna tell you
this story really quick.
It's gonna go real fast.
I was tutoring at
his learning center.
One day a kid walked in.
He couldn't multiply
polynomials.
I love multiplying polynomials.
He looked at me.
He said, can you really help me?
I'm like, dude, I got this.
He comes.
He sits down.
I help him.
The light turns on.
He turns the book, and he sees
the answer, and he looks at me.
He's like, oh, my gosh.
It's that easy?
I'm like, yes.
And I felt it.
I felt this thing that
I had never felt before,
and I was like, oh, no, no, no.
That's teaching thing.
We're not doing that.
So I told the lady at the front
desk who hired me-- I said,
listen I'm not working here no
more because if you're telling
me that this teaching
thing feel that good,
and I actually enjoy it, then I
gotta run from it because that
doesn't make money.
And I've already
been clear in my mind
that I would never be a teacher.
So I took off.
I said, well, I'll also help
until the end of this SAT
season and then don't call me.
But it was already in me.
The seed was planted.
It was growing really fast, and
I was trying to run from it.
So I move on.
I make more money.
And it starts getting worse.
So then I said, well, look.
I can always go back
to being an engineer.
I'm gonna go do this teaching
thing for a little while
and then I can always
go be an engineer.
I got my degree on
the wall, so they--
they can't take that, right?
So I become a teacher.
And that was 2002 and
I haven't look back.
Well, I've looked back.
I've only looked
at the salaries.
I haven't looked back
at saying that I'm
going to be going back.
And so my first year
teaching-- coming out of heart.
Heart calling me
to do this work.
I'm failing.
I signed up for a low salary.
I didn't sign up for
being broke and a failure.
I wasn't going to have both.
So I was like, look.
I'm going to go back to work
to making money thing if I
don't figure this out, so I
invited some students to lunch.
And I said, look.
I'll buy you all lunch once a
week-- a group of young men--
if you teach me how to
be a better teacher.
Tell me what I'm doing
wrong, 'cause I'll fix it.
If there's something I
can fix in why you're not
passing my class, and the fact
that I'm here for you 100%--
the fact that I'm here early.
I stay late-- I'll
provide food for you.
There's always
snacks in my room.
What do you need me to do
to help you pass this class?
Because I knew that algebra
wasn't just algebra.
Algebra was the gatekeeper,
because no algebra,
no high school graduation.
That's how California works.
You don't get
through high school
if you don't pass algebra.
So I knew that I could
see four years down
the line ahead of them.
Like, you don't pass this,
this is bad news down the line.
And many of them couldn't
see that for themselves.
And so Ever Forward
Club started out
of that-- these
lunchtime meetings where
I begin to hear them say, it's
not cool to be smart here.
I ain't gonna be no nerd,
no geek, no teacher's pet.
I'm not carrying
no heavy backpack.
All the things I remember
thinking and saying
when I was in middle school.
And I knew that my job
was never going to be,
I'm gonna tell you that
it's OK to be smart,
and you're gonna believe me.
Anybody have teenagers?
Have you ever tried to
tell a teenager something
that you know is
right, and they are
convinced that it's not right?
They'll wear you out.
They have way more
energy than us.
So I knew that my job
was not to tell them
that yes, smart is cool.
You can be smart.
It will pay off later, because
it's not paying off right now.
The payoff at the lunch
line isn't-- this smartness
ain't paying off there.
It's not paying off at PE.
It ain't paying off
at getting to school.
It ain't paying off on the bus.
If they can't see the
payout, why would they
invest the time and energy?
So we began to work
around the system,
and that's how the Ever
Forward Club was created.
I was not trying to
start a nonprofit.
I had already decided
to be a teacher.
Why would I be in some
nonprofit kind of thing?
That just seems totally running
in the opposite direction
of what I had worked
so hard for, I thought.
So I was like, we're going
to figure this thing out.
And so what I'm gonna
have you do right now
is I'm gonna have you hear
from some of the young men that
are in our program, who
have been in the program
either for a long time, or up
to just a couple of months.
And they're obviously
going to tell you
one or two sentences
about themselves,
or what school they're at.
Some of them are really
nervous right now.
When there was like one or two
people in here, they were like,
I got this.
And when people
started filling in,
they started getting
a little nervous.
So just smile at
them a little bit.
So they're all going to come up.
You're going to come
up at the same time.
All of you, come up.
Ambrosio, come up.
NATE: My name is Nate, and I'm
a student at [INAUDIBLE] High.
I became a part of
the Ever Forward Club
because I thought this would be
a wonderful experience for me.
This Club had done
many things for me,
including focusing more on
school and raising my grade.
My name is
DESHAWN SMITH: Deshawn Smith.
I'm 16 years old.
I got to Santa Rosa High School.
I've been a part of this
program for a year and a half.
I joined the program because
I saw my friends in it,
and honestly, they was having
fun, and was like, join in.
So hopped in and
it taught me a lot.
It made me become a better
mature young man-- educated,
get me through tough times,
and I appreciate what
this program has done for me.
DANA WILLIAMS: My name
is Daniel Williams.
I go to [INAUDIBLE]
Middle School.
I started this
program two years ago.
I like this program because
it's a good program.
It also helps us become
educated and strong men.
The reason why I joined
the Ever Forward Club
is because I thought
I should try it out,
and it turned out great.
So that's why I
stay in this club.
And it helped me
graduate middle school.
DEVON WILLIAMS: Hi my
name's Devon Williams,
and I go to [INAUDIBLE]
Middle School,
and I've been at Ever
Forward Club for two years.
I joined this Club
because I wanted
to be successful in life, and
Branch taught me to be mature.
And it helped me go
through bad things.
JAVIER SANDOVAL: Hi, my
name is Javier Sandoval.
I'm a junior at
Arise High School.
I've been an EFC member
for about six months now.
I joined to have
a safe environment
to share about problems that
I was going through back then.
I found out that everyone goes
through struggles, even if we
don't normally talk about them.
AMBROSIO PABLO: My
name's Ambrosio Pablo,
and I just graduated
from Arise High School.
And around September I'm gonna
start college at Berkeley.
I joined Ever Forward
my freshman year,
and throughout these
years, I've been
given a lot of opportunities
provided by him and by the Ever
Forward.
And I feel like if I hadn't
joined the Ever Forward,
I wouldn't have had the
opportunities that I had.
Also, throughout the years,
I've learned a lot of stuff.
He's also always on my back,
but, I mean, it's helpful to me
because sometimes I've
just fallen back on stuff
and I'm just like, let me
just give this a break.
But then he always calls
me up and he's like,
have you done this?
Just stuff like that.
He just tells me,
have you done this?
Like, always on my back.
Sometimes I get annoyed,
but it's helpful.
Straight up.
ASHANTI BRANCH: So
Ambrosio, come here.
Ambrosio.
Ambrosio is-- so he's going
to be starting at Cal.
So Ambrosio, actually, is going
to be on a full ride to Cal,
so I'm really proud of
him and all his hard work.
So I wanted you to be
able to hear from them.
And I think that if you
stayed afterwards and asked
them more questions-- I tried
to get them not to read it.
I was like, don't read it.
You wrote it, so you know it.
So just let it come through you.
And they were like, no.
I gotta have this thing.
So we're in a technology place.
You all get it, right?
The technology for them.
And so let it be.
So when the Ever Forward
Club began to grow,
and we ended up back at my alma
mater, Freemont High School,
there was a lot
of chaos going on.
There's still a lot
of chaos going on
at Freemont High School.
And I was thinking, how could
I try and be of service?
I was like a dean that
year, and I was like, well,
I'm dealing with
all these referrals,
and I keep seeing a
lot of our young men
just getting sent
out, kicked out.
I didn't have the
vision I was going
to be running a Club there.
I was like, well, I'm
here to do this job.
And then there was a need.
There was a need.
And the documentary
"The Mask You Live In"--
has anybody seen the documentary
"The Mask You Live In?"
A few of you.
The Representation Project,
which their founder
is Jennifer Siebel Newsom.
Her first film, back in
2011, was called "Miss
Representation,"
M-I-S-S, and it was about
the under-representation,
the misrepresentation,
of women around the nation,
around sports, media, music,
all different areas.
In 2015, released at Sundance
was "The Mask You Live In,"
and it was about American
masculinity and the challenges
our boys and young men face
in a society where they're
being told that this is
the limited list of what
it means to be a man.
Very limited list very.
A very small box of things
that show your masculinity--
that you're a man.
And so when they asked us to
come film at Freemont High
School, I said,
well, I'm working
with a group of young men.
They're kind of what they call
this thing the Brotherhood,
but they're not really
telling the truth often.
When we check in, they all say
they're a 10-- from a 1 to 10,
I'm a 10.
All them are 10.
And I'm like, now I know, as
a dean, they're not all 10s.
I'm like, my man, you just
got four referrals today.
How are you a 10?
And I know that you're
dealing with this,
and you're dealing with
that, but my job as a mentor
is not to tell their
stuff to the circle.
It's a whole space.
Even if I'm letting them
sometimes not really
always tell the truth.
And so I said, well, you can
come, but just so you know,
it's not really real.
It's kind of fake.
And they were like,
well, at least
we get to see they're
resist an opportunity
to let go of some stuff.
And I was like, OK.
OK, no problem,
because I was really
excited they were coming,
but in my mind, I was like,
you're not about
to be filming me
with a group of young men lying.
That's not gonna happen.
So I was trying to
figure out how do I
get them to talk about it in
a way that was disconnected
from them a little bit--
as a little bit out
of their direct way of having
to say, I'm dealing with this.
And so what you're going
experience right now
is what was created
for that day.
And if you see the
documentary, you'll
see a little bit of
that in the documentary.
It's now available on
Netflix and iTunes,
and we'll hopefully
be doing some--
AUDIENCE: Google Play Movies.
ASHANTI BRANCH: I'm sorry?
ASHANTI BRANCH:
Google Play Movies?
Google Play-- oh, I'm sorry.
See-- see what happens?
I told them I was
going to mess up.
I told them I was gonna mess up.
And Google Play Movies.
That's right.
How dare you.
I was already
sweating as it was.
OK, OK.
Reset.
I gotta get some water.
I need some water.
Got me.
I gotcha.
I got you.
And on Google Play Movies.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And so right now, in your
seat-- or probably you already
put it on the floor-- you
have a blank piece of paper,
and you have a pen, a marker.
So please grab that
marker, the piece of paper.
So we know we have people that
are viewing from other places,
and so if you have a
piece of paper handy,
or you have a journal there,
you can actually participate,
as well.
So it's just a
regular blank paper,
and so you can
participate wherever
you are watching, as well.
And so when we start
with the blank paper,
my first question to anyone in
the room is, what do you think,
or what do you find,
what do you believe,
is a purpose of a mask?
What is a purpose of a mask?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hide.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Hide something.
AUDIENCE: Transform.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Transform.
AUDIENCE: To fit in.
ASHANTI BRANCH: To fit in.
AUDIENCE: To put
out a fake facade.
ASHANTI BRANCH: To
put out a fake facade.
AUDIENCE: Safety.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Safe--
who said safety?
Safety.
AUDIENCE: Project
something about yourself.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Project
Those are excellent answers.
What I would like you do
is-- and I know some of you
are sitting with
friends, so do your best
to just kind of focus
on your own paper.
Do your best not to look
to the left or right.
I want you to just come from
whatever is in your mind.
And I want you, on this
paper, to draw a mask.
Whatever you think a
mask looks like is right.
Just draw a mask.
You can turn it over just so
you don't have any people trying
to look at your mask right now.
What I want you
to think about is
this mask as being a
representation of you.
I'm not saying it
looks like you.
I'm just saying it's like
a representation of you.
It came from your mind to
your pen, to your paper,
and you drew it.
So just think of it as
a representation of you.
And so what I would
like you to do
is I'd like you, on
the front of the mask,
to think of three
characteristics
that you gladly let the
world see about you.
When you leave the
house, and you go out
into the world, what are those
three characteristics that you
would say, I show the
world that I'm this.
I'm these three things.
Three characteristics or
phrases that you represent
that you let people see.
There's no talking.
Thank you.
Please write those on the front.
And once you've finished
those on the front,
then turn your paper over.
So now if the front of the
mask representation of you
are the three things
you show the world,
what do you think I'm going to
ask you to write on the back?
Somebody laughs.
They're like-- say it again?
AUDIENCE: Things you hide.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Maybe.
It may be things you
hide, but it may just
be things you just don't talk
about-- maybe things you just
leave unsaid, like
no one brings it up.
I don't bring it up.
It doesn't exist.
maybe there's things you just
leave that people can just
guess if they want, but I don't
really talk much about that.
So I'd like you to write
whatever-- to your level
of comfort-- three
things that you just
don't show the world-- you just
don't talk about-- on the back.
Three words or phrases-- those
three things on the back,
please.
And when you finish, I want
you just to ball the paper up.
And if you're in
a satellite place,
you can just-- you may
not want to throw it
at people in the room
'cause they're probably
right in front of you.
But in this room, we're
going to do something.
I want you to ball it up.
I want you to stand up.
You need your hands free.
I'll have you stand up.
And what I'm going
to have you do
is how about we have the
first two rows stand up,
and on this side, and I want you
all to kind of face this way.
Everyone's gonna
stand, but I'm gonna
have you all face this way.
Have you all face that way.
And what I need you to do is I'm
gonna have you close your eyes.
You're like, what?
What is happening here?
OK, trust me.
Well, do your best to
trust me, if you can.
I want you to imagine that this
piece of paper in your hand
is turning into snow.
You feel it?
Can you feel the snow?
It's like a snowball right now.
And what I want you to do
is, except for the people who
are right in the middle--
I don't want you to hit
the person right
in front of you--
I want you to hit someone
with this snowball
on the opposite
side of the room,
but you gotta keep
your eyes closed.
I don't want you
to aim at anybody.
I want you to just throw it,
and it will hit somebody, pray
maybe.
Now, this is supposed to be fun.
So if you are kind of
the person right now
who's not feeling like fun--
you're not in a fun mood--
I would say you can not do it.
But I want you to at
least throw your mask
and just throw it to the
air, and it will work out.
It always works out.
So I'm gonna have
you close your eyes.
And I'm gonna say
3, 2, 1-- wait.
Now don't do it yet.
I'm gonna tell you
what I'm gonna say,
then I'm gonna say it.
I'm going to say 3,
2, 1, snow throw.
And when I say snow
throw, you just throw 'em.
It's gonna be incredible.
Just watch.
So here we go.
OK, now close your eyes.
Here we go.
3, 2, 1, snow throw.
Now you can open your eyes.
Now you should find one.
You should find one.
Everyone should just find
one, but don't open it.
Don't open it.
You should find one.
AUDIENCE: We didn't get any.
ASHANTI BRANCH: If you don't
have one, we'll pass one.
Do you need one?
AUDIENCE: I found one.
ASHANTI BRANCH: You got one?
There's one right there
by that bag right there.
Can I have that bag right there?
Awesome.
Thank you.
Everyone has one?
Who's missing one?
I got an extra one.
Everybody got one?
Awesome.
We good?
OK.
So you can have a seat.
I want you, right now,
to take a deep breath.
Take a deep breath.
Young man.
Thank you.
Take a deep breath.
OK.
Now, here's where it
gets a little tricky.
Sometimes in this activity,
in this workshop-- so
we've done this workshop,
this last school year,
with about 5,000 people,
parents, teachers, young men,
young women in schools.
And so people bring
us into their teams
to do this workshop.
This is just the first part.
And what we found
at the beginning--
the reason I'm having to tell
you this disclaimer before you
can open it is because sometimes
people were opening it,
looking for something.
And I want you to know
that you're not really
looking for anything.
This is the gift
you've been given.
Because one of my mentors
said, showing up is about 90%
of success.
Now, you may have
heard 98%, 95%.
Some percentage of success
is a high percentage
of just showing up.
So whatever you have is
somebody showed up today.
I'm really thankful
you all showed up.
But they showed up,
and they said, well,
even if I don't
write anything, I'm
gonna participate a little
bit by balling this paper up
and throwing it at somebody.
So you're not looking
for something inside.
So if it's blank, it's
supposed to be blank.
If it's illegible and
you can't read it,
it's supposed to be illegible
so you can't read it.
Anything inside is just extra
to the gift for somebody
just showing up and
saying, hey, I'm
gonna just give a little
bit of myself in this space.
So what I'd like you to do,
carefully, respectfully,
is to open the paper, but don't
talk about it to your neighbor.
Don't talk about it
to your neighbor.
So what I need is I
need some volunteers.
And we gotta move.
I gotta move quickly.
I need maybe five
volunteers who would
be willing to read
one of the words
from the front of the mask.
I'll have you help,
and then, yes, sir.
You there, you, and you.
Anybody on this side?
You wanna volun-- OK.
And then I'll--
OK, please start.
Read one word from the front.
AUDIENCE: Happy.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Thank you.
Will you pass it?
AUDIENCE: Poised.
AUDIENCE: Smart.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Male.
AUDIENCE: Curious.
ASHANTI BRANCH:
Poised, smart, curious,
AUDIENCE: Confidence.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Confidence.
AUDIENCE: Energetic.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Energetic.
Hold it right there.
You're good.
Those qualities-- do you
recognize those, working here,
for those that work here?
Do you recognize
those qualities?
Smart, energetic,
poised, hard-working.
There's a few males here.
Those are the
qualities that we show,
so hopefully you recognize.
I've been to a
workshop where people
read one word from
the front, and I said,
do you all recognize
those qualities here?
And people were like, uh.
I was like, well,
you all wrote them.
You all said that's
what you show.
Do you know that it's
possible for some people
not to see what you
think you're showing?
At this point it gets a little
harder, a little trickier.
And it may have been tricky
when you were asked to write it.
Maybe your stomach was churning.
Maybe your brain was spinning.
Maybe the connection between
your heart and your head
was like in a battle,
like, don't do it.
Do it.
Don't do it.
Whatever happened when you wrote
the back may have brought you
to a certain different place.
And you'll experience it
again right now, maybe.
Please turn the paper over.
And can I have a few
volunteers to read
the words that are on the back?
Now if you're in the overflow,
in one of the side rooms,
maybe you can just
read your own and just
listen to what we are going to
hear happening in this space.
So just look for a hand
and then pass it, OK?
So this is from the back.
AUDIENCE: Personal stuff.
AUDIENCE: Fear.
AUDIENCE: Sad stories.
AUDIENCE: Personal
family relationships.
AUDIENCE: Tears.
AUDIENCE: Insecurity.
AUDIENCE: Fear of failure.
AUDIENCE: Impostor, unqualified.
AUDIENCE: Struggles.
AUDIENCE: Watch YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Respectful.
AUDIENCE: Stress.
AUDIENCE: Childhood.
AUDIENCE: Lack of
family connections.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Can
you take a breath?
Take a deep breath.
So what do you--
what's happening?
What do you notice?
What's happening in your head
and your body and your heart?
What are you noticing?
AUDIENCE: Empathy.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Empathy.
Can you say another
sentence about empathy?
AUDIENCE: Being able to feel
what a room is feeling like,
anonymously.
AUDIENCE: We're probably all
closer onto the negative side
than we think.
AUDIENCE: I feel more
connected to other people,
as opposed to connected
to myself only.
AUDIENCE: I feel like I'm not
the only one feeling certain--
some of those things.
ASHANTI BRANCH:
So no matter where
I go to do this
workshop-- whether I'm
at a middle school or 98th
Avenue in deep East Oakland;
whether I'm at a private
school in San Francisco;
whether I'm working with
some parents at a parenting
workshop; whether I'm
in Nashville, Tennessee;
whether I'm in Seattle,
Washington-- what I experience,
what I've observed, is
that so often people
don't realize how
much we're dealing
with some of the same stuff.
As an educator, you know that
you have to show up in class,
leave the junk in the car, go
up in front of the students,
be on the show, and when
you get back in the car,
you can pick it back
up on the way home.
And I imagine maybe some
of you have to do the same.
And the question is, do you
just tell everybody everything?
Like, when they
say, how you doing?
You say, oh, let me
tell how I'm doing.
Let me.
Thank you for asking.
I've been waiting for
somebody to ask me all day.
Most times, when people
say, how you doing?
They are already
like three feet away
by the time you answer, because
oftentimes we don't really
mean, how you doing?
We just have gotten
comfortable with how
you doing being just
a way to say I'm
really kind of noticing you.
Have you ever experienced it?
Think about it the
next time somebody asks
you how you're doing,
see if they're actually
caring how you're doing,
or is it just our way
of greeting each other?
Try it next time.
The next time somebody
says, how you doing, say,
I am so glad you asked.
Let me tell you, and watch them.
Watch their face.
They're just gonna
be like-- try it.
Try it today.
It'll happen in the afternoon.
How you doing?
So glad you asked.
Sit down for some coffee.
And what I believe is
that, because we are human,
we say it because it's what
we've been taught as kindness.
It's just a greeting.
So how do we deal
with the real stuff?
When we're in a high-performance
environment, when we're
in a high-stress environment,
like middle school
and high school, how do we
deal with the real stuff
when we can't really
deal with it there?
I wish that Ever Forward
Club didn't have to exist.
When I started
teaching, I was barely
learning the teaching thing.
I wasn't trying to start
anything on the side,
but the teaching
wasn't reaching them,
because they were trying to
pretend that the baggage wasn't
real, that they were showing up
to school super silly, happy,
whatever they were doing,
but they had a harder filter.
Their filter was harder, so
it was kind of leaking out
into their day-to-day actions.
As adults, we have
more practice.
We know, hey, I'm not
showing none of that.
I'll go in and get myself ready.
None of that
happened last night.
That didn't happen.
That didn't really just happen
this morning on my way to work.
It didn't happen.
I didn't just get that
text at lunch time.
It didn't happen.
Let me just get back to work.
And so what I've
learned, and what
we have learned in
Ever Forward, is
that providing these young
men a safe space to talk
about what's really
going on in a safe space.
I don't expect them to be able
to talk about that stuff out
there.
Not yet.
Our society's not
ready for young men
to be totally into
their emotions.
There can be an anger.
Anger gets you respect.
You can be super
funny and silly.
That'll get you some points.
But you can't be sad.
You can't be afraid.
And so what I've experienced,
in working with adults
and working with
parents, is that, if you
don't find a place--
it may not be at work,
but if you don't find a place
that you can go regularly
to be like, let me just talk
about what's really going--
not to be fixed, but just to
be heard, just to be seen,
I believe that we do
ourselves a disservice.
If you're a manager and
you're working with people,
and you've got people
in your team who may not
be doing everything
the way they should
or whatever, maybe you
could ask, how's it going?
Can we just have a real talk?
That's why I don't say get real.
Getting real is like, can I talk
about what's really going on
and feel safe that
it's not going
to jeopardize my valuation,
or my status among my team.
It wasn't until I joined a men's
team, in 2010, that I really
felt like I was being seen by
other men that were pushing me
to be better, like I could
talk about successes at work
and people were not
like, oh, whatever.
It was like, yeah!
Nice!
That's powerful.
It's powerful to
be knowing that you
could have people around you who
care about you being the best
you.
So they help you
through the down times,
because the only
way to move back up
is to get through
the down times.
We're all going to have them.
But if we're always
pretending like everything's
always perfect, then when
do we ever get support
to get stronger, to get better?
So if you don't
have that, I would
encourage you to find that.
In the Bay Area here, there's
plenty organizations--
men's teams, women's
teams, or organizations
that support all
different groups
that you would feel that you
would want to connect to.
What does that feel like to
be able to talk about what's
really going on and
know that it's not
going to get back to people
that could make decisions
about your life?
Say, you know, I'm really sad.
I'm really dealing
with some sadness.
I have an extreme
fear of failure.
I have extreme fear of police.
I'll see one walking
into Starbucks,
and my heart will
start pounding.
Pounding, like I want to leave.
So where do I go
talk about that?
Who do I tell that I'm felling
this anxiety every time
I see some flashing lights,
because I have a big mouth
and sometime I talk a
lot, so I talk back.
And so I'm like, OK.
I better not say nothing back.
I better say yes sir, no sir.
I feel like I gotta do that
to keep my life sometimes.
Who do I talk about to that?
Some people can't understand it.
And so I'm so glad that
you all came today,
and I think that one of
the things that you have
on your seat is you have ways
that you can get involved,
like you can support the young
people in your community.
Right now, our program
is in its growing phase.
The Stanford d.school
fellowship has really
helped me to be able
to tell what we're
doing in a better way,
clearer, using design thinking,
starting with empathy, starting
with the human-centered design,
like am I designing?
Am I creating a
program for them?
Am I asking them
what is it that they
need so that we make sure
that the program exists
to support them?
And so we have a
Google Serve day
that Adam is helping us put
together-- all the information
on that paper.
You can sign up to
volunteer with us.
You can just be
in touch with us.
You can just send
information out
to people about
what we're doing.
You can participate in that.
You can also donate.
I'm not asking you to leave
your job to go do this work.
I made that sacrifice.
And so if you feel inclined,
and if it calls your heart
to support us in
a financial way,
we would encourage
you to do that, too.
Maybe there's something
else-- some other cause
out there that's really
calling your heart
and you've been
kind of ignoring it.
Maybe you could begin putting
some attention to that.
So I'm really super
thankful for this time.
And I wanted to
leave a few minutes.
We only have maybe
five or seven minutes
left if there were any questions
for the young men, for myself.
But I thank you for being here.
I thank you for participating.
The mass that you
have, we will collect.
We are envisioning what the
data looks like as we travel
all over doing this workshop.
So we will collect these.
So if you could just leave
them on the seat if you leave,
or you can pass them forward.
But if there's any questions,
we'll take some questions.
If they can be aimed
at myself, Ambrosio
back there, or any of
the young men here.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming out here.
I appreciate you
sharing your story,
taking off your mask for us.
And I appreciate
all the great work
that you're doing with these
young men over there, as well.
Question is are
you doing any work
with men in the South
Bay area or peninsula?
And if so, just want to hear
a little bit more about that,
and how to get involved in that.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Thank you.
So this year we have
been doing workshops
all over the Bay Area, and
being invited to other states
to do workshops.
So we have a chapter that's
at Jordan Middle School, which
is in Palo Alto.
And we have been
invited to JLS, which
is-- I don't wanna say
what the JLS stands for,
but there's another
middle school that we
went to a screening
for the documentary.
And so there's
teachers there who
want us to do some work
with some young men there.
We go into schools and we do the
Taking Off the Mask workshop.
It's usually about
a two-hour workshop.
And so that's our first level
of engagement with the students.
And once that
workshop happens, they
will know-- the
administrators will
know-- whether the young
people are connected,
like they're ready to get real.
Because the work
is you gotta help
them understand that there's
a reason that we're not
getting real-- because
we're not allowed to.
And so there's a school
in San Jose that had just
been-- so I'm reaching out.
So if you know schools,
if you know principals,
if you know a school that
we should reach out to, we--
so this academic school year,
'16-'17, our goal is to take
10,000 people
through our workshop.
This past year was
5,000, and so we're
going to be building the team
of facilitators that go out.
And so we're ready.
We're in that stage of like,
what is the distribution
model of how we get our work out
to a bigger part of the world?
And we're raising
money right now to-- I
took a leave of absence to
take the Stanford fellowship.
So that's one year off.
So I'm purposely not
looking for a job right now,
because this is what
I should be doing.
And it's also scary.
It's scary to go from
a high salary to low.
It's even scarier to go from
just a little bit of salary
to none.
And I feel it.
But I'm also knowing
that that's why I do it.
And it's going to happen.
Thank you for asking.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Have you done talks outside
of the state of California?
ASHANTI BRANCH: Yeah, we
got invited to Minnesota,
in the Minneapolis area.
And they're screening--
we did a talk there.
I was on the Minnesota
Public Radio.
I'm going to be in
Texas in the summer.
So we're doing a lot more.
So right now, as we begin
to reach out-- but yeah,
we do talks wherever
anybody wants us to come.
AUDIENCE: So how do
we get in contact?
I would be very
interested for you to come
to Atlanta, Georgia for a talk.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Fantastic.
You have my information
on that card,
but if you want a
[INAUDIBLE] before we end,
I'll give you my information.
I would love to do that.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate it.
ASHANTI BRANCH:
Thank you, brother.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Ashanti,
thank you for coming.
This is super educational.
I knew nothing
about the program.
Super pumped.
I want to thank these young
gentlemen who got up there.
It took a lot of
courage to do that.
And I know you're saying
they're on their iPhones.
As a really shy kid growing
up, we didn't have iPhones.
I had a piece of paper.
I was told memorize it.
And I thought you guys
did a really great job
articulating yourselves, and
articulating the program.
So I just wanted to thank you
for participating in that.
I think it was super cool.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
thank you so much.
We saw him it at Wisdom
2.0-- one of the few standing
ovations of three days of
just heartfelt presentations.
So I actually wanted
to thank your mom
for doing such a great job.
I guess for those of us that
might be parents, be parents
down the road, how did
you do such a good job?
AUDIENCE: It took
a lot of prayer.
Ashanti really was a good kid.
He really was.
I think only one time his
temper got the better of him,
and that was in
elementary school.
And I think he turned over
a desk he was so upset.
But I think that's the
only time where I can ever
remember having to
go to the school
to deal with a lot of
discipline with Ashanti.
He was really a
good big brother.
He was really a good first son.
Does he have his moments?
Yes.
But we all do.
So that's why I had to
keep praying for him
and the rest of my children.
And just-- life is life.
With children, you have to
let them know, I love you.
But one thing he knew,
when the teachers told me
he did something, I said,
I'm believing the teachers.
I believe you, but I'm
believing the teachers.
But he knew that I had
his back on things.
But he knew that I
expected high of him.
I remember one year when he
was getting ready to graduate.
Ashanti said, well, I've decided
I'm not going to college.
I said, oh yeah?
You're not going to college?
Nope.
I've decided I'm not
going to college.
I said, OK.
Well just get ready because
you need to find a job.
So that means that
everything you
will be paying for yourself--
your food, your clothes,
and everything, since you feel
you're not going to college.
And I think he was
playing a game with me,
because he went to college and
won a bunch of scholarships.
But I had to let him know
that's your decision.
So we have to just
support our children.
ASHANTI BRANCH: There's a
lot she's not telling you.
I'm just gonna say I'm
gonna let that one go.
Thank you, Mom.
Thank you very much.
ADAM QUAYLE: Thank
you for coming,
and thank you, Ashanti, for
sharing your wisdom with us.
ASHANTI BRANCH: Thank you, man.
Appreciate it.